Noruega es un país famoso por su clima extremo
con largos días de sol en verano, largos
días de noche en invierno y sobre todo mucho frío.
También, es conocido por su enorme estado
del bienestar - como todo buen país nórdico;
por sus fiordos y tal vez, por encima de todo,
por el salmón ahumado.
Y ojo, que no es ninguna tontería.
La industria pesquera noruega es una de las
más modernas y más importantes del mundo.
Sin embargo, aun con todo, en los últimos
años, lo que más se está haciendo notar
es la apuesta noruega por el medio ambiente,
especialmente en la lucha contra el cambio climático.
Y, amigos, donde mejor podemos ver toda esta
apuesta es probablemente en el sector del
coche eléctrico
Veréis, Noruega tiene el mercado de coches
eléctricos más desarrollado de todo el planeta.
Aquí, casi uno de cada dos coches que se
vende es un coche eléctrico... o al menos
un híbrido.
Pero eso, no es todo
Para 2025, es decir dentro de nada, el gobierno
de Noruega quiere que en este país no se
vendan ni más coches de gasolina, ni más
coches diesel.
Solo electricos e hibridos.
Cuesta imaginarlo, ¿verdad?
Hablamos de toda una revolución: tras más
de 100 años de monopolio del motor de combustión,
sus días están llegando a su fin, al menos
en este país.
(Aquí, la “fiebre” por lo eléctrico
llega hasta los barcos.
Dos empresas están desarrollando un proyecto
conocido como el Tesla de los Mares para poner
a navegar el primer barco autónomo que funciona
con baterías eléctricas.
El primer Yara Birkeland, el nombre formal
de este proyecto, está previsto que comience
a navegar a finales de 2018).
Ahora bien, puede que os estéis preguntando:
¿Cuál es el secreto de Noruega?
¿Cómo diantres ha conseguido este país
que los coches eléctricos sean tan populares?
¿Es que acaso los noruegos tienen una conciencia
especial?
Bueno, puede que haya algo de factor cultural
en todo esto… pero a decir verdad, la realidad
es un poco… menos idealista.
La clave, amigos, de todo este boom del coche
eléctrico está, sobre todo, en los elevados
incentivos con los que el gobierno lleva años
apoyando esta industria.
Fijaos,en Noruega cuando quieres comprarte un
coche, si eliges un eléctrico te ahorras,en
impuestos, básicamente... una fortuna.
Por ejemplo, no tienes que pagar el IVA, que
cuidado, no es poca cosa, es del 25%; ni tampoco
el impuesto de matriculación u otros impuestos
adicionales.
¿El resultado?
Atentos:
(Según un reciente estudio, por ejemplo,
un Tesla S que costaría unos 140.000 dólares si tuviera
que pagar todos los impuestos que pagan los coches de gasolina,
gracias a todos los incentivos viene a salir por unos 70.000.
Es decir, el ahorro es del 50%.
No está mal ¿verdad?
Por si fuera poco, entre otros muchos beneficios
estos coches tampoco tienen que pagar los
peajes en las carreteras ni los parquímetros.)
Vamos, en otras palabras… así cualquiera,
¿verdad?
Por cierto, en este país casi toda la electricidad
es de origen hidroeléctrico: es decir hablamos
de electricidad barata y limpia.
Por eso, con todas estas políticas verdes
que hemos visto y algunas otras, el gobierno
noruego espera reducir en un 40% las emisiones
de CO2 en los próximos años.
La mismísima Constitución noruega,
en su artículo 110, se preocupa del medio ambiente:
(“Todos tienen derecho a disfrutar de un
medio ambiente que asegure la salud y de una
Naturaleza cuya capacidad productiva y diversidad
sean preservadas.
Los recursos naturales serán utilizados partiendo
de consideraciones a largo plazo y universales,
que salvaguarden este derecho también para
generaciones venideras”.
Artículo 110, Constitución de Noruega).
Sin embargo, amigos, no es oro todo lo que
reluce…
Noruega es un país muy rico, con un estado
del bienestar enorme, pero con un “problemilla”…
o al menos una característica que pone furiosos
a los miembros de Greenpeace:
Hablamos de la importancia que la producción
de petróleo tiene en este país.
Pero, ¿Hasta donde llega esa dependencia?
Veámoslo.
¿ADICTOS AL PETROLEO?
Si cogieramos el Delorean de Marti Mcfly  y nos fueramos hasta principios del S.XX, nos encontrariamos
con una Noruega con una economía muy rudimentaria.
Prácticamente, lo que aquí se hacía era
pescar, pescar y... pescar.
Si avanzamos en el tiempo aunque la cosa mejora
bastante, lo cierto es que a finales de la
década de los 60 Noruega no estaba en la
lista de los países más ricos, para nada.
De hecho, su renta per cápita venía a ser,
teniendo en cuenta los diferentes niveles
de precios, la mitad que la de Suiza…
("En 1960 el nivel de vida en Noruega era
sobre un 30 o 40% más bajo que en Suecia
o en Dinamarca.
Ahora el nivel de vida de Noruega es sustancialmente
más alto que en ambos países”
Así que podemos preguntarnos, ¿Qué pasó
para que de pronto Noruega se convirtiese
en uno de los países más ricos del planeta?
Pues, amigos, podemos decir que todo empezó
a cambiar en 1969.
En ese año se descubrieron las primeras grandes
reservas de petróleo…
Y ahí sí, a partir de ese año dio comienzo
una época dorada que llevó a este país
a convertirse en uno de los mayor exportadores
mundiales de petróleo y gas natural
Sí, Noruega pasó prácticamente de ser un país más a ser la Arabia Saudita de Europa.
Como os podéis imaginar… toda esta “revolución
petrolera” que vivió el país supuso la
llegada de mucho dinero… dinero que ayudó
a poner en pié la Noruega que todos conocemos.
(Hoy el petróleo y el gas natural juegan
un papel absolutamente clave en este país.
En 2016, por ejemplo, casi el 40% de las exportaciones
y más de una quinta parte de las inversiones
tuvieron su origen en este sector del petróleo
y el gas naural).
Y por supuesto, el gobierno obtiene su parte.
Fijaos, según los años y, claro, el precio
del petróleo y el gas, los ingresos que el
gobierno obtiene de esta industria suponen
aproximadamente entre 1 de cada 6 y
1 de cada 4 euros que el gobierno recauda…
Vamos, lo que se dice, un pastizal.
Y más ingresos públicos… suele significar
más gasto público.
(“Un tercio de todos los noruegos en edad
de trabajar no hacen absolutamente nada.
Más de un millón de ellos viven del dinero
del Estado.
Y todo se debe al petróleo”.
Sí, así es.
En buena medida podemos decir que el modelo
noruego que consiste en un estado del bienestar
muy grande, y en el control público de muchas
de las grandes empresas del país, tiene mucho
que ver con el petróleo.
Sin embargo, amigos, la caída de los precios
de esta materia prima y también de la producción
ha llevado al gobierno a tomar una medida
muy controvertida:
Por primera vez en 20 años, el gobierno noruego
ha otorgado nuevas licencias de exploración.
En concreto han sido 10 nuevas licencias de
exploración petrolífera en el Mar de Barents,
en pleno Círculo Polar Ártico.
Y la verdad, este movimiento ha puesto furiosas
a organizaciones ecologistas como Greenpeace,
que por cierto han llevado al gobierno a los
tribunales, acusándole de violar los Acuerdos
de París de lucha contra el cambio climático
y también de violar su propia constitución,
que como hemos visto antes tiene muy en cuenta
la conservación del medio ambiente.
El caso, es que como veis, parece que el compromiso
verde de Noruega tiene algunos límites.
(“Noruega se ha propuesto ser un líder
mundial en la acción climática, pero la
expansión continua de la producción de petróleo
y gas podría eclipsar los beneficios de los
esfuerzos nacionales de reducción de emisiones
de Noruega".
Peter Erickson, científico del Instituto
del Medio Ambiente de Estocolmo.
Pero claro, el estado de bienestar más grande
de todo el mundo… hay que pagarlo.
(“Nosotros, como país, somos “petroólicos”
[...] dependemos tanto de los ingresos del
petróleo que, al igual que los alcohólicos,
queremos parar pero no sabemos cómo”.
Thomas Nilsen, Editor of the Independent Barents
Observer.
Ojo, esto no quiere decir que Noruega sea
como otros países en los que solo hay petróleo,
para nada.
El país tiene cierta dependencia pero ni
punto de comparación con por ejemplo Venezuela
o Arabia Saudita.
Aquí las cosas son muy distintas, entre otras
cosas porque aunque el gobierno tiene mucho
peso en la economía - algo más del 50% del
PIB -
ha procurado ser un país abierto a los negocios
y también aprovechar todo este dinero procedente
del petróleo para impulsar actividades productivas,
lograr una educación de mucha calidad y también,
ahorrar.
EL FONDO DE FONDOS
Lo cierto es que para ser un país que ha
hecho tanto dinero con el petróleo es muy
distinto a lo que estamos acostumbrados.
Oslo, la capital de Noruega, no está plagada
de rascacielos, ni de gigantescos centros
comerciales, ni de extravagantes construcciones financiadas por el oro negro.
(En otras palabras, puede que hayan gastado
mucho, pero probablemente la gran clave del
éxito de Noruega es no haber derrochado…
como si han hecho muchos otros países.
Aquí el gobierno, decidió muy pronto ahorrar
una buena parte de los ingresos procedentes
de los recursos naturales.
Y no se les ocurrió nada mejor que crear
un gran fondo soberano para invertir la riqueza
generada comprando activos por todo el mundo.
Ojo porque estamos hablando del mayor fondo
soberano del planeta.
Ni siquiera países como Arabia Saudita o
Kuwait tienen tantos ahorros.
Fijaos:
“El fondo soberano de Noruega alcanza un
patrimonio de un billón de dólares”.
¡Un billón de dólares!
Ojo, esto equivale a una fortuna ahorrada
por el gobierno de casi 190.000$ por habitante.
Y es que los noruegos, en vez de gastarse el dinero del petróleo
a lo loco decidieron invertir su dinero en
empresas de todo el mundo.
Hoy este fondo tiene dinero invertido en más
de 9000 empresas de 78 países diferentes.
Entre ellas algunas tan conocidas como Apple,
Nestlé, Shell o Alphabet, es decir, Google.
Sí, podríamos decir que el gobierno noruego es propietario de una parte de YouTube.
Y… ¿sabéis qué?
Uno de los objetivos de este fondo es poder
llegar a sustituir los ingresos que genera
el petróleo.
Me explico, como os podéis imaginar las inversiones
generan… beneficios.
Pues bien, desde que se creó este gran fondo
la rentabilidad media anual ha sido del 5,7%.
Así que, si esta rentabilidad se mantuviese
en el tiempo, de media cada año Noruega obtendría
más de 50.000 millones de dólares en beneficios,
el equivalente a una cuarta parte de todo
su gasto público.
No está mal, ¿Verdad?
A todo esto, claro, hay que sumarle los ingresos
que cada año el gobierno obtiene del petróleo
y también de muchas empresas locales, que
aunque son publicas, funcionan con criterios
de mercado.
Vamos que casi podríamos decir que en Noruega
no tienen mucho de qué preocuparse, ¿verdad?
Pues esperad un momento… porque a pesar
de que el nivel de bienestar parece que tiene
pilares sólidos, el gobierno del país está
empeñado en lograr diversificar su economía
y hacerla más competitiva para perder esta
dependencia que todavía tienen del petróleo.
LAS REFORMAS
Desde 1927 el Partido Laborista de centro-izquierda
ha sido el partido más votado en todas las
elecciones generales de Noruega.
Pero aquí, las mayorías absolutas no son
algo común.
(En 2013, una coalición de partidos de centro
derecha, entre ellos el Partido del Progreso,
conocido por sus posiciones radicales en materia
de inmigración, logró aupar como Primera
Ministra a Erna Solberg.
Se la conoce como la Merkel noruega.
Recientemente en las elecciones del pasado
11 de septiembre 2017, esta coalición fue
reelegida.)
La intención, amigos de este gobierno, es
como decirlo, distanciarse de algún modo
de lo que ha sido conocido como el modelo
noruego.
Este gobierno quiere mejorar la competitividad
del país reduciendo impuestos, especialmente
a las empresas, e impulsando la inversión,
tanto la pública como la privada.
Eso sí, como hemos visto, también apuesta
claramente por seguir desarrollando la industria
del petróleo.
En cualquier, si algo tienen claro en Noruega
es que el crecimiento, el desarrollo y la
innovación son las mejores fórmulas para
conseguir bienestar y también mejorar el
cuidado del medio ambiente.
En fin, turno para ti ¿Crees que Noruega
es un modelo para la gestión de los recursos naturales?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like y no
olvides suscribirte al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.